come here come here
I'm just gonna put handcuffs on just for
now
where's the knife
anymore I'm so sorry
how old are you I'm 12 years old where's
the knife
Disneyland
you threw it where
it's upstairs not not right there it's
the room this is the other room it's
right behind the apartment this
apartment right here so where would the
knife be on that side
yeah I'm so fucking sorry
I'm sorry I don't know what happened
this is something about it what's your
mom think
what what's your mom's name
I'm so sorry
come over here so we're out of the
paramedics way
I'm so sorry hey what's your name
for me so crisscross on the grass okay
just sit there for a second you don't
have the knife on you right no I swear I
don't sorry I don't and don't
worry
[Music]
is there anybody else inside the house
hey how would I get to the knife is
there the back side I can show you okay
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
I really didn't want it just happened
like this this sucks I'm so sorry you're
probably gonna go to jail he's gonna
live the rest of my life
that's it right there okay
do me a favor we're gonna sit crisscross
applesauce right here okay
first apartment right here
take him
[Music]
he threw the knife over here
it's right there okay
[Music]
stick your hands out like this for me
do you have any cuts on you
where at
which which arm
s did you cut yourself
actually I'm at my right arm it just has
this moment
sorry I don't know what the fuck uh mom
and then fire and emsa was
[Music]
hey real quick I'm gonna take you out of
handcuffs and I'm gonna take your hoodie
off okay
that way we can see the cut that you
have
take your hair off for me
is it just those
look old are they old
um yeah those are a little this one
those are old
do you have any new
that's from today
with the same knife
do what what's that can you watch her
for just a second so I'm getting her to
gloves
[Music]
thanks
what's happening with her
what's gonna happen with her I need to
go to the hospital I don't know yet you
don't know yet you go with the hospital
we'll come and talk to you okay
just be calm okay I don't know what
happened tonight
I don't know what the fuck I did I'm so
sorry I love you
foreign
I think we're good I'm gonna stick your
hoodie back over okay okay
let me clear my car and put in my car
take her to my car okay
okay ready we're gonna get up there we
go
let's go this way
we're gonna figure it out okay I'm so
sorry I don't know what happened
yep
[Music]
what's your last name
how do you spell your first name
yeah
what's your birthday
okay let's back up so you can have room
to you have shoes or anything no just
thought okay I have stickers
in my in my socks right now a lot of
stickers
is uh he going to the hospital
okay
it's okay it's okay
[Music]
can you work on calling crime scene yeah
I'll call crimes here all right
Whitton is texting you mom's info I
already got Mom's well I got Mom's name
and phone number okay so um I'll call
Crime Scene uh well I'll step by the car
everything
[Music]
all right I'll be out here if anything
okay all right
how old is he he's nine years old nine
years old okay all right
I'll be right here okay
just hang tight
you're not going anywhere right now
what did you
what was that
[Music]
right now let's just
you know bro calm down a little okay
I don't know what we're gonna do right
now all right
right now we're investigating
take a deep breath okay I know there's a
lot of things going on right now just
take a breath I don't know why I did it
just take a breathless let's not think
about it
[Music]
math teacher he he had a cancer so he
wasn't at school for a really long time
and yesterday was his first day back in
school
I really hated math but I started to
like it because he was there
[Music]
oh
what the fuck is my birthday from the
hospital he's in the hospital right now
little lady yeah
pretty sure he will there's the doctors
doctors are all over there
he will take care of him your mom's over
there too
[Music]
is he just never gonna forgive me it's
okay
take a breath
[Music]
s you know
nobody's here in life okay all right
okay
[Music]
who watches you guys when your mom goes
to working on that
it's it's it it's just me
you mean your brother yeah babysit
because I have I have a two I have a
three-year-old brother he just turned
three in October but he goes to estad
every week he used to his status every
weekend but we got a day early today
we just went to his dad's house and
dad's house huh
yes
okay
I already know that was that I already
know I'm gonna go to jail for the resume
you are not going to jail
nobody knows that all right okay
cool
we are gonna get through with this okay
[Music]
am I gonna be able to go back to school
huh
bye
um
right now
calling people
I don't know
when
possibility yes I don't know
I can't answer that for you all right
okay
I guess I want you to go back to school
bye to a lot of people
say good morning
it's really bad let's not think about
that okay
I think about that
calm down
a lot of things are going on right now
okay a lot of things are going right now
okay okay
are the handcuffs unnecessary I'm a good
child
very good child about this
[Music]
I don't even know if my mama want me to
live there anymore
[Music]
uh
I'm not saying that I will go to jail
but if I want to go to jail how long
would I be there for
so that's
kind of a difficult question
um so first of all you're too young to
go to jail
so juvenile detention in jail two
completely different things
um
because you're 12 correct
so
you got to be at least 13 to go to jail
[Music]
um
but
I have no idea
if you do or don't and how long you'd be
there
okay
get that spelled off
all right
we'll get you those handcuffs
it's me
let's go through that door right there
there's some call somebody
Hey Joe how do I get in
okay all right sounds
I'm sorry was that
yeah
hi everybody
okay so I'm gonna take you back here
just one out of cuff sort of yeah we're
gonna teach that across okay okay
Lean Forward
sorry my little flashes
just go ahead and work put earlier
go ahead and turn your hands over
sleeves for me
thank you
okay our restroom's ready where's the
bathroom sadly we only have one oh okay
sorry and if you need water or soda okay
it's just a one Cedar
um I've got everything for him
[Music]
she was asleep she was good does she
know no she doesn't know that I'm not
telling her anything yet okay I'll let
you do it I understand we're gonna go
this time no thanks I'll take this guy
I'll bring it with us we're gonna come
over here your mom's here too they just
pulled in okay okay
I'm going to kind of walk you through
everything
and we'll just go from there
and we'll just hang out in here for now
okay
well we're going to talk to your mom
your mom
do anything to drink to bring a soda
or water
do you want to SmackDown it's fun okay
because we've got I've got snacks it's
really cold in our building so we have a
blanket for you too
okay okay and then
um let me ask are these the clothes
you're wearing all night okay and then
if you ever need food or anything let us
know obviously
okay I'm gonna sit down with you if
that's okay
okay so right now he's breathing they're
doing everything they can but it's I
just just talked to the doctor and she
was saying it's all good things right
now
[Music]
I I know that this is a probably I mean
hey Sarge I'm uh with Mom uh what's up
I'm working on it right yeah she just
walked in I'm working out right now
all right
okay and I'm gonna have uh
okay Roger
all right I'll call you back yep
okay and I'll send you his information
and uh all right give me one second and
I'll
Roger I'll call you right back here in
about five minutes
all right I know 142 today sorry about
that that was my supervisor but I said I
cannot imagine what you're going through
right now I've never been aggressive or
anything
yeah I don't like her like like they
bully each other like brother and
sisters but it's never they never like
fist fight or do anything like that so
this is just completely it was in bed it
was downstairs trying to sleep I don't
know why she even went down there like
what the hell is she I don't understand
any of it all I know is I heard him
screaming like the worst scream ever and
I thought maybe he was having a
nightmare so I started to try to wake
him up and there's blood everywhere and
he said she stabbed me she's stability
and he started going in and out of
Consciousness and so that's what they
told me to put him on the floor do chest
compressions and and I couldn't find my
daughter anywhere I was screaming her
name and she ran out after she did it
because she was scared and
so right now she's safe and she's in
custody with us right now uh it is a
really
over like I'm I mean as this is a very
um
there's no words I can tell you that's
gonna
those ranchers we're going to be looking
for yeah
never would have assumed she'd do
something like that that's crazy to me
like she was like I don't know why she's
just fucking crazy I don't know she
doesn't even curse like I don't know
it's just yeah I can she's not a bad kid
like she doesn't do bad things you know
what I mean like she's totally out of
trouble it was weird yeah
what's her name
his ex-husband you're talking about this
is their father it's his father yeah
Levi
he's on his way up here right now and I
called you earlier and you can totally
disregard that because now the nurse
you're totally good yeah
with
all the time like they look at things
like that's their granddaughter too like
she doesn't get left out like I just
don't understand why she would have so
much especially
bedtime yeah it's so weird
no well there's nothing I don't blame
you there's nothing that you could have
done differently
I
mean there's nothing that you could have
done differently I mean don't blame
yourself for any of this
him like
his home he's supposed to feel safe
well and again like my own sister you
know that he will never forgive her she
will never it will never be
now between them like what the hell is
she picking
well done I mean she's 12 years old at
that age you know there's a lot of
things going on in the brain she
probably wasn't thinking
hello
okay he's here so I'll meet him in the
window she's gonna meet you in the
waiting room for you back here
yeah this is the waiting room with the
children hospital the children's
emergency rooms
yeah the children's side
okay
Saint Francis Children's side yeah
so real quick I know that I'm the
probably the last person you want to
talk to right now but so what we need is
to get as a search waiver for the
apartment so we can go through have our
crime scene detectives go through and do
a thorough investigation of this
so you don't have to authorize us to do
this but I mean it would really Aid in
our investigation I'm trying to figure
out everything that's going on we know
what happened my daughter says she got a
knife and stabbed him three times well
we need to find the knife and we need to
do all that can I be there uh I just
don't know I don't have anyone there
right now well there's nothing it's not
like I mean if there's any like we're
not looking for any like I I'm not
saying I'm just sitting like drugs or
anything illegal that's not for that I
just don't yeah it's fine to sign it I
just
I just don't have anyone I can be there
right now well and that's things there
won't be any like because this is like
crime scene detectives that go through
and it could even be homicide that goes
through and we do have two cats there
too I don't want them to get out and
they're not gonna get out they're okay
yeah so your name is
and you're only authorizing us to go
through there
did she not get the knife for you guys
when well she got
well if it's inside the house said it
was in her room okay well so that's the
thing we can't just go in there yeah uh
so the only thing I need to get from you
is your signature right here uh here's a
pit right here yeah
and then
today's date six
what uh what's your apartment what's the
I'll give you guys uh
let's go back over there and give them
some time
she was upstairs he was downstairs
asleep and she just heard screaming
come down there and
she thought that he was just having a
nightmare until she saw the blood Okay
so
and
shit
makes you wonder what's going on in a 12
year old